일단 상반기에는 그 거래량이 좀 많이
줄어들었죠 올해 하반기까지는
전망이 좋지만은 않다 내년을 지켜봐야
될 거 같은데 좀 지켜봐야 될 것
중에 하나가
[음악]
내일 사람입니다 오늘은 올해 하반기
전망과 이슈에 대해서 얘기를 해보도록
하겠습니다 올해 일단 상반기에는
거래량이 좀 많이 줄어들었죠 1월
달이 가장 안 좋았고 2월 말에 이제
거래량이 조금 살아나면서 지금까지
그래도 좀 거래량이 오르긴 했는데 제
개인적인 생각은
하반기에 이렇게 좀
눈에 띄게 좋아지거나 뭐 그럴 거
같진 않습니다 그 연준에서
금리를 더 올린다는 얘기를 좀 많이
하잖아요
금리가 좀 더 올라갈 여지가 있기
때문에 하반기에는 지금보다 오히려
조금 더 안 좋아질 수 있다라고
내년을 지켜봐야 될 것 같은데 금리가
조금 내려가는 시점부터 거래량이 좀
회복될 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 올해
하반기까지는 좀 전망이 좀 좋지만은
않다 뭐 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고요
지켜봐야 될 것 중에 하나가
첫 번째로 오피스 시장입니다 자연
공실률이라 그러죠 그래서 일반적으로
발생하는 공실률 수 때문에
운영이 되고 있는데
그러니까 이제 제가 말씀드린 그런
지역 있잖아요 강남이나 이런 데는
그래도 상대적으로 공실률이 좀 적긴
한데
앞으로
인건비 상승이나 아니면 이제 임대료가
계속 올라갈 거거든요
금리가 올라가면서 지금 건물을
신축이나 리모델링 하신 분들이
임대료를 좀 높게 책정을 할 거거든요
임대료가 좀 상승된 여지가 있고
그리고 기존에는
원래 이제 회사가 투자를 좀 많이
받았었어요 투자를 좀 많이 받으면서
사무실을 좀 큰 데로 옮겼는데 최근에
이제 좀 투자가 안 되면서 좀
사무실을 이전하거나 사무실을
확장하는 경우가 좀 전보다는 많이 좀
줄어든 경향이 있습니다
앞으로이 오피스 시장이 좀 어떻게
변할지 여러분들 좀 지켜보시면 좋을
것 같고 그 두 번째로는
새로운 시장들이 좀 많이 얘기가 오고
가고 있는 거 같아요 그래서
우리나라가 지금 고령화가 계속되면서
노인
복지주택에 대한 관심이 좀 많더라고요
업체들 좀 만날 때마다 그런
실버타운이나 이런 복지주택 관련해서
좀 얘기를 많이 하는 거 같아요
2025년도에 이제 초고령화 사회라고
하잖아요 이런
쪽에 좀 트렌드가 좀 변하고 있다
우리나라에서 사업을 한다면
노인 주택에 대해서 저도 사업 계획을
앞으로 좀
짜봐야 될 정도로
기업들이
관심이 많이
가지고 있는 것 같습니다 그리고
코 리빙에 대해 관심이 많아요 그래서
코 리빙이 뭐냐면 공유주거 전에
영상에서 이렇게
촬영을 좀 했었죠 그런 공유 주거하는
업체들이 좀 과감을 받을 것 같아요
최근에는 대기업도이
시장이 좀 들어왔고
글로벌 업체도 지금 우리나라 프로테크
업체랑 같이 조인해 가지고이 사업을
본격적으로 하려고 합니다 아무래도 좀
1인 가구가 좀 많아지고 공유하우스
같은 경우에는 보증금이 많이
들어가거나 근데 최근에 이제 전세사기
이런게 많잖아요 상대적으로 이거는
보증금이 많이 들어가지 않고 이미 다
인테리어나 이런게 다 돼 있기 때문에
커뮤니티가 워낙 잘 되어 있기 때문에
좀 젊은 1인 가구분들이
관심을 많이 가질 것 같고이 시장이
좀 많이 커질 것 같습니다 여러분들도
좀 이런 코 리빙 공유주거 하는 이런
시장이 어떻게 커지는지 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 세 번째로는 이제
코로나가 풀리면서
외국인 관광객들이 좀 많이 눈에 띄게
많아졌어요
앞으로 더 많이 올 것 같습니다
지금도 많아졌는데
코로나 전과 비교해서 아직 한
50%가 좀 안 됐더라구요
외국인 관광객 수가 근데
앞으로 저는 더 많아질 거라고 생각이
되고 한류 10평이 지금
워낙 좋기 때문에 이러한 관광사업
호텔 쪽이 더 좋아질 것 같습니다
코로나 때까지만 해도
호텔을 멸실하고 이제 오피스로 변경을
하는 경우가 좀 많았거든요
근데 지금은 오히려 오피스를 안
만들더라구요 안 만들고 호텔 그
상태로 그대로 남겨두더라구요 앞으로이
호텔 사업 여행과 관련된 이런
사업들이 좀 어떻게 변화할지 좀
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 최근에
전망과 이런 이슈들을 봤을 때
앞으로 이제 여러분들이 하반기에
투자를 하신다고 하면은 제가 계속 전
영상에도 말씀드렸지만 일단은 잘
팔리는 동네의 건물을 사셔야 되고
지금까지는
금리가 높기 때문에 대출을 좀 많이
받는 거는 좀 권하지 않습니다 저금리
때나 이제 풀 레버리지에서
투자를 했었는데
감당할 정도의
컨디션이 안 된다라고 하면은
법정 수준의 대출을 받아서
투자를 하는 건 좀 권해드리고 싶고
그리고 앞서 설명드린 것처럼
외국인 관광객 수요가 되게 많아지기
때문에 그 외국인 광각인들이 많이
오는 그런 상권들이 있잖아요
그쪽도 좀 유심히 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다네 그래서 일단 좀 정리를
해보겠습니다 하반기 시장은 어찌됐든
좀
금리 인상에 대한 이슈가 있기 때문에
되게 좋아지거나 그럴 거 같진
않다라고 저는 예상을 하고요 그리고
오피스 시장도 지금까지는 괜찮긴
하지만
앞으로 이제 좀 여러가지 이슈가 있기
때문에 어떻게 변화할지 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같고
고령화 관련된 그런 사업들도 여러분
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같고 코 리빙
사업 그러니까 공유하우스 사업이
성장한게 이제 1인 가구들이 좀
많아지면서 좀 많이 성장을 했거든요
지금 플레이어들이이 세상이 좀 많이
들어와 있기 때문에이 시장이 좀
어떻게 앞으로 커질지 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 마지막으로
지금 외국인 관광객들이 우리나라에 좀
많이 오고 있기 때문에 이런 호텔
관련 사업들이 좀 많이 성장할 것
같거든요 이런 것도 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같고 제가 말씀드린 이런
포인트들을 조금 기억하셨다가
앞으로 조금 빌딩 투자하는데 있어서
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다